new photos johnny today in comeback mode
the 59 year old was mobbed by fans in
paris days after wrapping up his concert
tour
while johnny is feeling the love his
legal battle with amber heard rages on
depp has countered his ex's appeal of
last month's verdict she insists on
continuing to litigate this matter
we have to protect her clients interests
that's johnny's attorney camille vasquez
the trial's breakout star sat down with
cbs mornings and revealed depp's legal
strategies amber heard's team did not
want cameras in the courtroom why did
you want cameras in the courtroom i
think it was important to the client
for johnny it was about finally being
able to tell his story
the only person that i have ever abused
in my life is myself
i think he came into this case thinking
he had nothing else left to lose gail
another strategy most of depp's legal
team was under 40 years old this case i
think called for a younger team
why why did you think that because the
parties were young right and they
resonate with a younger audience and
you need their perspectives i think
young people have a fresh perspective on
especially these issues abuse me too
those were the issues as for those false
rumors that camille and johnny started
dating during the trial well the
attorney has a theory on that i think
they started because people like
love stories they like
to make things up right um doesn't mean
they're true and obviously in this case
they weren't true and i don't think
there's anything wrong with caring for
your clients i was fighting for his life
his name it's perfectly normal to give
him a hug and make him feel like he was
protected
[Music]